i want to ask steve something because i
i saw a clip that came up and i don't
know if it's going to bring up anything
you know bad for you but i remember
seeing you in india
so pissed off at a certain when they
were doing the sex thing
and was that because why was that
because you only saw clips of you like
dude you guys were just [ __ ] pissing
me off
right it's i i don't mind it but you see
wild boys was super
homoerotic we just got a real kick out
of
wearing g-strings and uh and like doing
like
you know homosexually suggestive stuff
because we felt that like the the macho
sort of jock like you know like
homophobic people we we loved the idea
of getting a rise out of them we were
pushing our culture we were ahead of our
time but i i told the all the guys i was
like hey guys
that's it man like there's no like uh no
more gay stuff
so the first thing they put you in was
the gay stuff
right and uh and and like for the rest
of wild boys
he was having an inner struggle for the
rest of wild boys like it became a thing
like the movie airplane like
looks like i picked the wrong week to
quit acting games
that's funny he'd be like not into
actually and then like
then the next day like he'd do something
super gay but
it's weird like it's just dynamics of
like when it's two dudes
filming it just happens like even on
robin big like
there was like a lot of like homo rot
like you know like jokes
like it just happens i think the dynamic
of
of two guys you know traveling around
together but it was funny like
something right but at the time yeah it
was it was ahead of its time and now it
would be totally cool
but you know the world wasn't as
accepting of a place
like just that short time ago you know
as it is now
and you know um sometimes i've i've
watched
an episode of wild boys and i'd think to
myself god that wasn't gay enough
and then i hear like mtv's notes or like
um some
other people we work with to be we gotta
tone down the gay thing they think we
gotta tone down the gay stuff and i was
like i watched that same episode
i thought it wasn't gay enough i
remember uh
i want to say it was like right after
wild boys came out
my dad and i were in florida
went to the skate shop and there were a
couple kids skating
outside the shop and i just kind of like
walked by proudly
sort of displaying myself like thinking
all these kids these kids are gonna
recognize me
my dad's gonna be like proud of his son
you know
i'm walking by like kind of proudly and
and the one skater kid
right in front of my dad the one skater
kid says uh
to the other one yo dude that's the guy
for wild boys
and and the other guy doesn't even look
up he goes those dudes are
gay
that's funny dude yeah you know what all
the all that stuff was
funny like and i was like i was just
like who cares what people think like
it's funny like and now we all like
like it's just whenever you know we were
pushing it
like oh my god dude tell us like uh
about the
what was the there was like a gay
magazine or a gay online website
and they were like talking about jackass
and how like
it was such a hit uh would say that yeah
it said like knoxville of course is the
most the best uh
the best looking of the jackass boys but
stevo seems to be the most likely
to uh you know just to suck your dick if
you got him drunk enough
i think it was like village voice yeah
that it said basically
roughly exactly that oh my god
you guys seem to have that chemistry
from the start because i've uh when you
when you were doing the flip into the
elephant [ __ ]
that was one of the first bits we filmed
yeah you guys barely kind of
had even known each other but you guys
are like showering together
in that well we were struck we were
strapped for time
[Laughter]
it was just all the skies there like but
but really like
a long time ago before jackass i
realized like whatever you do it's gonna
be way funnier if you're naked
like oh yeah 100 it basically comes down
to that like and
unfortunately on tv you can't be totally
naked so the g
string is the closest you know you can
legally get but
i mean g strings are just rad um
even though i always preferred the more
conservative brazilian cut
brazilian kind are awesome too they are
that was with the cheese because people
always say oh you're you're leopard
print
thong no to cheetah brazilian
man
especially if your butt's not like up to
snuff like maybe
maybe uh if it's not in shape as good a
shape as you'd like it to be
the brazilian cuts can be very
flattering yeah you know and
and uh as as you can see on any woman at
the beach you know wearing one
you know um but if you but
you know it's funny i i found out i
looked up um
thongs or g-strings and it it's the
first article of clothing that man ever
wore
wow you know you know yeah the original
it's
yeah like basically i mean
it's to you know basically keep the
elements out especially if you're
a woman i am i assume but um but yeah
it's
i mean or if you're a man it's just for
the the most basic
article of clothing is the g string
there you go you know
and yes but i i think um yeah it was
just
whatever you do doing it naked it just
makes it ten times funnier
and yeah you know and if you're just
because it's cooler
a lot of stuff that we did i don't i i
like and feel like people were so
worried about like being
people thinking that they were gay like
in it
you know at different times or back then
more than they are now
because of people trailblazers like us i
mean i'd like to think that
we are a part of like opening like
people's minds a little bit you know
right i would say that that's fair to
give you guys some credit at least for
kind of
pushing that envelope for like for my
generation we grew up watching you guys
do all your gay [ __ ] on tv
we single-handedly we single-handedly
rid
the world of homophobia you fixed it
single-handedly
[Laughter]
together holding hands together
yeah dude